many thanks to all our friends on the
five welcome to Hannity this is a Fox
News Alert and we are following three
major breaking news stories tonight
President Trump he continues to work
towards keeping a very key campaign
promise he's now calling on Congress to
work to pass a massive tax reform plan
that should help you the American people
of course after years of suffering under
the Obama administration
also tonight the destroy Trump media
they proved they don't care about the
Constitution the rule of law they're in
full complete meltdown freakout mode
over the president's daca decision which
of course is constitutional and doesn't
assert the power of Congress also
tonight the clock is ticking for leaders
on Capitol Hill 14 weeks they have to
get their act together and enact the
president's agenda before the end of the
year
tonight we will hold Washington
accountable we will lay out very simply
for Republicans what they need to
accomplish that's tonight's very
important news breaking opening
monologue
all right the president once again left
the sewer the swamp that is known as
Washington DC left the area to take his
tax reform message directly to you the
American people so earlier today at
North Dakota President Trump he called
for a dramatic Reaganesque overhaul of
the federal tax code so desperately
needed
let's take a look our country and our
economy cannot take off like they should
unless we reform America's outdated
complex and extremely burdensome I mean
this is so complicated and so burdensome
our tax code if we want to renew our
prosperity restore our opportunity and
re-establish our economic dominance
which is what we should be doing then we
need tax reform that is pro-growth
pro-jobs pro worker pro-family and yes
pro-american my administration is
working with Congress to develop a plan
that will deliver more jobs higher pay
lower taxes for businesses of all sizes
and middle-class families all across the
nation so it's not only business taxes
its middle-income families its families
at
every level every level tax cuts here's
a question to the people in DC do they
care about the 50 million Americans in
poverty the 50 million on food stamps
the 94 million out of the labor force do
they care that we have a 51 year low in
terms of homeownership rate in this
country now what the president is
calling for today is going to have a
profound positive impact on the
Forgotten men and women in this country
and the country as a whole
workers would have more money in their
pockets after not seeing real raises in
years companies they'd be able to see
lower taxes that means they can hire
more employees invest in new
technologies build factories and
manufacturing centers and just like
President Reagan GDP growth and federal
tax revenue it will soar ironically
Washington will have more money to waste
and of course the destroy Trump media
they don't care about any of this
they're not interested in the truth
they're not interested in the business
of offering solutions to people that
have been left behind
what is the media's main objective they
create false narratives outright lies
and they're obvious goal is to try and
damage dealer genom eyes president Trump
so instead of talking about his tax plan
his new reforms the media is hysterical
like 24/7 hyperventilating about
President Trump and his decision to be
constitutional on the issue of daca and
give Congress an additional six months
to do their job come up with a
law-abiding constitutional solution just
take a look at how insane how obsessed
the media is in attacking the president
and the Attorney General it's so obvious
it's not even a dog whistle anymore it's
just flat-out bias flat-out
discrimination that they're touting
coming from this White House
increasingly there's a sign out there
that's been hung up in the White House
we're outside the way I'll say if you're
not white you're not especially welcome
and that just that that is so sad is
this a stability issue because I feel
like some might argue when you see him
off prompter he doesn't really seem to
be there what do you really connect
with the reality of the situation I
don't think he really understood his
decision and I'm not being facetious
there people inside the White House that
were saying that he really didn't
understand the impact of his decision
for years he has been an outspoken on
abashed admirer of the eugenics based
race specific immigration bans of the
1920s Klan era in u.s. politics I mean
Jeff Sessions has always stood for this
stuff but so has Donald Trump as a
public political figure more lies but
that was not the end of the media's
hysteria they also tried to spin the
president's decision to respect the
Constitution respect co-equal branches
of government the real balance of power
they try to portray this watch the word
of the day was cruel cruel and then
cruel again take a look today's actions
by the President and Jeff Sessions is
nothing short than cruel as well as
compassion and we're just going to go
and cruelly just take them away from
this life Trump could just tell Congress
to do it without terrifying and scaring
the bejesus out of all these kids in
other words there's a cruelty there this
is a signal and it's a signal to say I
can do something that a lot of people
think is cruel this is someone this was
a cruel inhumane and unnecessary move
that the shop administration did today
his critics say the decision was cruel
immigration advocates say the move to
cut them off it's cruel if you guys
could zoom in on the Statue of Liberty
right now I suspect she'd be shedding a
tear this is a dark day for our country
they got the memo cruel cruel cruel
notice they're like robots in the
mainstream media and I got to tell you
something the president has already
given Congress eight months now they
have six additional months if you want
Dock a go ask your congressmen and
Senators now what the media has been
trying to do to President Trump is
they've been doing this for months they
are creating lies and a false narrative
and again they want to smear this
president in order to try and scare the
American people into turning against him
they peddle nonsense lies 24/7 and what
the president actually did instead of
stomping on the constitution shredding
the rule of law by the way even Obama
recognized he didn't have the right to
do it he said like 20 times
while President Trump is giving Congress
now an additional six months to do their
job legislate and come up with a
solution apparently members of the leak
establishment media they need to go back
to school maybe take a class on how the
government works because it actually
takes Congress they make the laws we
have three branches of government and
the president guess what he signs the
laws there are limits to executive
authority and power Obama said it
himself the media seems so absolutely
apoplectic to just go after everything
Trump so let's have Barack Obama himself
give them a lesson here's the former
president over the years well before he
signed daca and after he signed daca
talking about his own limits of
executive power media watch listen learn
is this cruel I mocked the Constitution
don't make fun of it don't suggest that
it's on American to abide by what the
founding fathers set up it's worked
pretty well for over 200 years
sometimes when I talk to immigration
advocates you know they wish I could
just bypass Congress and change the law
myself but that's not how democracy
works the notion that I can just suspend
deportations through executive order
that's just not the case now I know some
people want me to bypass Congress and
change the laws on my own but that's not
how that's not how our system works
that's that's that's not how our
democracy functions that's not how our
Constitution is written the problem is
is that you know I'm the president
United States I'm not the Emperor of the
United States my job is to execute laws
that are passed if we start broadening
that then essentially I would be
ignoring the law in a way that I think
would be very difficult to defend
legally so that's not an option if in
fact I could solve all these problems
without
passing laws in Congress then I would do
so but we're also a nation of laws
that's part of our tradition a nation of
laws that's not how our Constitution
works and then he did it anyway
Wow and here's what now Speaker of the
House Paul Ryan told me back in 2014
about fighting President Obama's illegal
unconstitutional executive order on daca
take a look if the president follows
through on his threat for executive
amnesty what do you have in terms of
tools at your disposal to stop him from
doing that well first of all it's
unconstitutional so we're already going
through the court system on other
unconstitutional executive orders that
he is he has worked on and we would add
this to the pile so the president is
respecting co-equal branches of
government and enumerated powers he is
literally restoring right before your
very eyes the way the founders intended
this to be so if the liberal
establishment mainstream media disagrees
with that then maybe they need to stop
pretending and fully embrace their
leftist ideology and admit I don't care
about the Constitution or the rule of
law all the President did here wants to
do here is follow the law of the land
and protect the American people for
example and this is something the
destroy Trump media will never tell you
which is why we take over for them I've
been down to the border over a dozen
times I've seen what goes on there
firsthand crime drugs illegal
immigration and even trafficking of
people there are good people do come
into this country they want a better
life but not everyone is good I have
proof back in 2014 during one of my many
trips to the border well and I've been
there so many times i sat in a briefing
a security briefing with then Texas
Governor Rick Perry and what we learned
was shocking over seven years span
illegal immigrants that's right in Texas
alone had committed 642 thousand crimes
including murder and other violent
crimes against Texans watch the security
briefing criminal areas have been
responsible about six hundred forty two
thousand offenses criminal offenses you
look up there in topless sexual assault
there's close to eight thousand victims
six hundred
42,000 crimes so they're down tonight
to Texas in Texas alone yes over by over
200,000 individuals their criminal
history reflected there were they they
were committed over six hundred forty
thousand crimes that's the cost of not
security so is your corrupt media they
paying any attention you know innocent
Americans many of them have lost their
loved ones and American families have
suffered because politicians they just
refused steadfastly to enforce
immigration laws and what does the media
done about it well on this show for
years we've interviewed on numerous
occasions family members who lost loved
ones at the hand of illegal immigrants
we've heard firsthand of their
devastating stories more so than any
other show that we know and here's why
it's important that we bring this up the
media the left in this country they love
to claim they have a monopoly on
compassion and acceptance and and
conservatives a mean-spirited and
hard-hearted but you know what yet they
attack the president for following the
rule of law respecting the Constitution
enumerated powers co-equal branches of
government and actually enforcing
immigration laws and advocating for
extreme vetting to protect Americans
against our enemies in reality the left
is a bunch of hypocrites because if they
really cared about the safety and
security the American people your pain
your suffering in other words they show
us phony compassion because if they
really cared they would want to enforce
the laws you know where was the media
talking about the disastrous Obama
economy 50 million Americans in poverty
eight million more than before Obama was
president 50 million on food stamps 13
million more after eight years of Obama
ninety-five million Americans out of the
labor force lowest labor participation
rate since the 70s the worst economic
recovery since the 40s lowest
homeownership rate since in 51 years so
other foot than us did you ever hear
about this from anybody else in the
media do they even care about the
Forgotten men and women in this country
no it appears they don't and they don't
have any standards there's no morals or
decency anymore look at for example an
Tifa the media rushing to condemn
out-of-control violence
well what took them so long how many
people need to be attacked and beaten
before the media is going to speak out
against the radical and Tifa leftist
here's my larger point tonight President
Trump
ran on a specific pro-america pro-worker
pro-growth agenda and you know what it's
time for Congress they ran on basically
the same thing at least Republicans did
that they now benefit the American
people and get their hands dirty stay up
late at night and do their job and get
some sense of urgency about what they're
supposed to do and they better be paying
attention and that means you Mitch
McConnell mister 18% approval rating
Congress needs to get focus get to work
they need to start passing tax reform
seven brackets to three slash
middle-class tax rates they're paying
too much if you slash the corporate tax
rate to around 15 percent allow
multinational companies that have
trillions parked overseas repatriate the
money at a low rate that will create
millions of jobs in this country and
help people out of poverty and get them
off of food stamps get them back in the
labor force and Congress also needs to
get moving
guess what start building the wall you
know what put doors all over the wall as
long as people come here that want to
participate and adopt our values and be
a part of our family we're fine with
that but we do need to vet them so
Congress needs to pass legislation to
bring about energy independence we have
millions of high-paying career jobs out
there and waiting and we won't be
depending on countries that hate us for
the lifeblood of our economy and finally
Republicans in Congress keep your word
we please repeal and replace Obamacare
get your act together this isn't rocket
science these are all the things you all
ran on president Trump has a higher
approval rating than the media by far
and all of you in Congress and what have
you guys been doing all these years